A compiler is a program that translates a
high-level language program into a functionally
equivalent sequence of machine instructions,
i.e., an assembly language program.
A compiler first checks that the high-level
program is correct, i.e., that the statements
are well formed, the programmer isn't asking
for nonsensical computations,
e.g., adding a string value and an integer,
or attempting to use the value of a variable
before it has been properly initialized.
The compiler may also provide warnings when
operations may not produce the expected results,
e.g., when converting from a floating-point
number to an integer, where the floating-point
value may be too large to fit in the number
of bits provided by the integer.
If the program passes scrutiny, the compiler
then proceeds to generate efficient sequences
of instructions, often finding ways to rearrange
the computation so that the resulting sequences
are shorter and faster.
It's hard to beat a modern optimizing compiler
at producing assembly language, since the
compiler will patiently explore alternatives
and deduce properties of the program that
may not be apparent to even diligent assembly
language programmers.
In this section, we'll look at a simple technique
for compiling C programs into assembly.
Then, in the next section, we'll dive more
deeply into how a modern compiler works.
There are two main routines in our simple
compiler: compile_statement and compile_expr.
The job of compile_statement is to compile
a single statement from the source program.
Since the source program is a sequence of
statements, we'll be calling compile_statement
repeatedly.
We'll focus on the compilation technique for
four types of statements.
An unconditional statement is simply an expression
that's evaluated once.
A compound statement is simply a sequence
of statements to be executed in turn.
Conditional statements, sometimes called "if
statements", compute the value of an test
expression, e.g., a comparison such as "A
< B".
If the test is true then statement_1 is executed,
otherwise statement_2 is executed.
Iteration statements also contain a test expression.
In each iteration, if the test true, then
the statement is executed, and the process
repeats.
If the test is false, the iteration is terminated.
The other main routine is compile_expr whose
job it is to generate code to compute the
value of an expression, leaving the result
in some register.
Expressions take many forms:
simple constant values
values from scalar or array variables,
assignment expressions that compute a value
and then store the result in some variable,
unary or binary operations that combine the
values of their operands with the specified
operator.
Complex arithmetic expressions can be decomposed
into sequences of unary and binary operations.
And, finally, procedure calls, where a named
sequence of statements will be executed with
the values of the supplied arguments assigned
as the values for the formal parameters of
the procedure.
Compiling procedures and procedure calls is
a topic that we'll tackle next lecture since
there are some complications to understand
and deal with.
Happily, compiling the other types of expressions
and statements is straightforward, so let's
get started.
What code do we need to put the value of a
constant into a register?
If the constant will fit into the 16-bit constant
field of an instruction, we can use CMOVE
to load the sign-extended constant into a
register.
This approach works for constants between
-32768 and +32767.
If the constant is too large, it's stored
in a main memory location and we use a LD
instruction to get the value into a register.
Loading the value of a variable is much the
same as loading the value of a large constant.
We use a LD instruction to access the memory
location that holds the value of the variable.
Performing an array access is slightly more
complicated: arrays are stored as consecutive
locations in main memory, starting with index
0.
Each element of the array occupies some fixed
number bytes.
So we need code to convert the array index
into the actual main memory address for the
specified array element.
We first invoke compile_expr to generate code
that evaluates the index expression and leaves
the result in Rx.
That will be a value between 0 and the size
of the array minus 1.
We'll use a LD instruction to access the appropriate
array entry, but that means we need to convert
the index into a byte offset, which we do
by multiplying the index by bsize, the number
of bytes in one element.
If b was an array of integers, bsize would
be 4.
Now that we have the byte offset in a register,
we can use LD to add the offset to the base
address of the array computing the address
of the desired array element, then load the
memory value at that address into a register.
Assignment expressions are easy
Invoke compile_expr to generate code that
loads the value of the expression into a register,
then generate a ST instruction to store the
value into the specified variable.
Arithmetic operations are pretty easy too.
Use compile_expr to generate code for each
of the operand expressions, leaving the results
in registers.
Then generate the appropriate ALU instruction
to combine the operands and leave the answer
in a register.
Let's look at example to see how all this
works.
Here have an assignment expression that requires
a subtract, a multiply, and an addition to
compute the required value.
Let's follow the compilation process from
start to finish as we invoke compile_expr
to generate the necessary code.
Following the template for assignment expressions
from the previous page, we recursively call
compile_expr to compute value of the right-hand-side
of the assignment.
That's a multiply operation, so, following
the Operations template, we need to compile
the left-hand operand of the multiply.
That's a subtract operation, so, we call compile_expr
again to compile the left-hand operand of
the subtract.
Aha, we know how to get the value of a variable
into a register. So we generate a LD instruction
to load the value of x into r1.
The process we're following is called "recursive
descent".
We've used recursive calls to compile_expr
to process each level of the expression tree.
At each recursive call the expressions get
simpler, until we reach a variable or constant,
where we can generate the appropriate instruction
without descending further.
At this point we've reach a leaf of the expression
tree and we're done with this branch of the
recursion.
Now we need to get the value of the right-hand
operand of the subtract into a register.
In case it's a small constant, so we generate
a CMOVE instruction.
Now that both operand values are in registers,
we return to the subtract template and generate
a SUB instruction to do the subtraction.
We now have the value for the left-hand operand
of the multiply in r1.
We follow the same process for the right-hand
operand of the multiply, recursively calling
compile_expr to process each level of the
expression until we reach a variable or constant.
Then we return up the expression tree, generating
the appropriate instructions as we go, following
the dictates of the appropriate template from
the previous slide.
The generated code is shown on the left of
the slide.
The recursive-descent technique makes short
work of generating code for even the most
complicated of expressions.
There's even opportunity to find some simple
optimizations by looking at adjacent instructions.
For example, a CMOVE followed by an arithmetic
operation can often be shorted to a single
arithmetic instruction with the constant as
its second operand.
These local transformations are called "peephole
optimizations" since we're only considering
just one or two instructions at a time.